in a total film article King revealed he
was open to making sequels to Wonka he
pointed out how Ral Dal a writer who
didn't really write sequels nonetheless
kept exploring different things he could
do with the character of Willy Wonka he
wrote Charlie and the Great Glass
Elevator featuring Wonka And even had
plans to write a third book in the
series so there's plenty of potential
for continuation King said there's an
awful lot more Wonka story that we have
that we would like to tell it's not like
Dune part one where you go this is
what's happening in part two hopefully
it works exquisitly as a standal movie
but I would definitely like to do more
and I'd like to spend more time in this
world and meet some more OA lumpers